Michael kryon doesn't always get the
credit he deserves for importance and J
defying of a Sci-Fi writer he was in
addition to Jurassic Park kryon also
wrote the novels The Andromeda Strain
timeline Congo and sphere kryon
sometimes bypass writing a book allog
together instead writing a story
directly for the screen as he did with
his criminally overlooked 1981 film
looker the sci-fi movie satz as the
control that the media has over people
and in particular how much influence
physical attractiveness can wield ler
also predicted the main M stream
popularity of plastic surgery as well as
the fairly recent phenomenon of computer
generated celebrities and spokespeople
I'm sing I'm the perfect female time 18
to 25 I'm in addition luer is
underappreciated for the way it
pioneered the use of computer effects
and images in films having the first
true CGI character ever used in a movie
as well as using 3D computer shading
before Tron did Even though Tron often
erroneously gets the credit for doing
that first